45 seconds of logos however it's obvious
the movie is going to be so tedious I
almost wish there were more logos
Ubisoft now making video games and the
movies not only reading but scrolling
reading also for centuries is not only
how bad video game movies begin it's a
warning about the length of bad video
game movies please it right there
Knights Templar apple of Eden a key to
free will itself this is a rejected
national treasure too concept you
thought you could fool me movie but I'm
too slick for you also nothing in the
Bible explicitly states the forbidden
frozen Apple should they double back and
keep an eye out for suspicious pigs we
take you now to an unpronounceable city
in Spain the exact year Columbus left
for the Americas which doesn't seem
important up the connection to mention
but I assure you this bet nobody thinks
it is 10 seconds of super blurry weapons
manufacturing since movie adheres to
these something's wrong with my contact
lens style filmmaking I'm Sonic I'm a
knows little templarios then he will
accept his position at the scene asshole
you know the elaborate rolling pin at
backstory Ness is just a little too da
vinci code for my liking
da montanha Lois told Apple fans
annoyingly loyal since 1492 never but
the statement nothing is true can't be
true right because then something would
be true which would make the statement
nothing is true untrue somos Esther she
knows somewhere somehow someone
convinced the studio brass that this was
a badass thing opening they were wrong
of course which only makes their
treatment more impressive no seriously
movie about futuristic assassins sent
back in time chooses to open on a couple
minutes of a bird flying over mountains
is there a reason you don't know
still masks not only Jesus could survive
this but somehow after that crash he
ended up with three identically sized
scrapes on his face at 1.75 inch
intervals how did some handlebars do
this kind of precision damage how much
does a videogame based movie need to
rely on James Wan horror staples
apparently a lot not to be overly McCobb
not that I really care about that though
but still how likely is it for her and
to enter rigor mortis in a position such
that the incriminating necklace is not
only visible to basically gift-wrapped
the subtitle here says man speaking
Spanish backwards and I think that's
actually way more revealing for deaf for
half deaf people like me than it is for
the normal hearing audience all they
hear is gibberish but I as a
hearing-impaired viewer using the
subtitles know that he is actually
speaking Spanish backwards suggesting
he's a demon of Central American origin
something found Kyle's dad plays the
pronoun game instead of explaining to a
son when he just killed his mother
perfect illustration of the tailgating
black villain SUVs cliche this prison
shelf seems the perfect height for
finger painting and not much else yes I
saw we're almost 10 minutes into this
picture and I've only heard around 20
English words who is this guy why is he
in prison do we know do we care do we
know Lord wash away my sin will be is
trolling me for sure by having this line
of dialogue spoken over a clear centered
prison wall doodle of a hand jerking off
a dick like object Cal's life flashing
before his eyes consists of a
third-person memory of his mother some
stock footage of clouds and one of the
visualizers from Windows Media Player
also pretty sure this movie is
suggesting that in between life and
death this guy was given a chance to be
a time-traveling assassin and he said
yes and that may be one of the weirdest
sentences I've ever uttered face
touching denied
there are no Hospital safeguards in
place to keep this from happening and go
yes because he has an important lesson
to learn here about his non-working legs
that is better learned through
experience than lecture also I just like
watching people with no led function try
to outrun able-bodied people because I
have a jerk I understand that Sophia
told the other two guys to let him go
but no one else in the building heard
that so why isn't anyone else trying to
stop it
canter sweeps musics well then I still
have no clue what I'm looking at here I
have to your father wants for me he's my
patient this is my program
oh great suddenly I'm asked to shift my
empathy from fast better to Sofia
without so much as a have an apple it
allows I gonna recovered his burial site
if he's just accessing his ancestors
memories then why doesn't need to wear
the actual blades why not the whole
outfit and if he has to be connected to
something that is ancestor once wore for
some reason why pick the most dangerous
thing in his ensemble forcibly put it on
him and not tell him how it works and
doesn't see a 1492 record everything
okay you might expect me to send the
time travel or the lack of any
information about what's going on but
I'm actually here to send the record
everything
are there missions to the past where you
people don't record everything and if so
why also look Jeremy Irons is here
slumming us ass off
I'm sorry Kyle this is not the way I
like to do things how do you usually
like to do things with a prior
discussion and a mutual understanding of
the events that are about to take place
me do I start a vigil the irony here is
that ultimately epidurals are used to
stop pink yopa I don't mean to split
hairs here actually I do
but treat doesn't really want your past
she wants your great-great-great
great-great great-great-grandfather's
basket that's memory matters long I mean
is this movie so vague because they
expect viewers to know the game or
because they realize no one but game
players would come to see display or
both same with a song stay with what he
has no idea what's happening food or
clothes the script synchronization take
retardation achieve so are they
synchronizing is mine to his ancestors
mind in the past or are all of Aguilar's
memories passed down genetically and
they just found them inside Kyle's brain
pretty sure the games have explanations
for these questions but movie don't got
time for that also that these are just
Aguilar's memories what if he doesn't
remember something do we just give it or
what if you remember something
incorrectly or what if he just remembers
mundane like middle-aged donkey races or
something say how can we maximize our CG
budget
I know make it so that there's so much
fire the smoke covers everything and
then we can fudge the details
brilliant Aguilar apparently remembers
being behind an eagle and swooping down
over
battle also is this an attack bird or
just a regular bird flying too close to
a battle or is the bird the DP of the
movie does it actually take this long
for caldas app into the past or is this
just some weird bird based
self-indulgent bull most reminiscent to
explaining the machine while you're in
position and moments from starting
submission Mad Max horsey road I want
them to cut back to count when he's
doing normal things like riding a horse
what does that look like is he riding in
circles is he riding a place this bad
guy literally abandons the reins of his
coax to go back and fight cow Aguilar
and what do you know the horses keep
running and the carriage stays on the
path and it even overtakes the coach he
was chasing oh now all of a sudden it's
going to be an issue if one of these
carriages has no driver of course Wow
what you yourself said he couldn't
change anything you can't change what
happens tell he was watching some dead
dudes memory so yeah good job looking
Cal also a movie is almost 1/3 over and
haven't explained a goddamn thing
Allen launches the speech he gave to the
UN because it's convenient to the plot
on the artifact the Apple the screen boy
is 12 percent made up of the word Apple
I have to report to the elders the
elders this movie is intentionally came
with you at this point who are the
elders not only you for asking but it
probably doesn't matter people don't
know who care about their civil
liberties they care about their standard
of life citation needed all the
bloodlines of die dark bar one did Allen
forget about the other assassin dudes he
has living in this complex
Jesus color junkie cinematographer I
mean there are 37 different shades of
grey and they shot alone it's not
surprising you'll know more if you
cooperate and he'll cooperate more if
you say it's 10 percent clearer than
this bakery this isn't the first time
Fassbender has been in a movie where a
man in a black turtleneck is on a
seemingly endless quest to find a
magical Apple your kids on pen well yeah
I guess you're right
all pimps definitely deserve to die also
can we get anything back story on Cal
that doesn't involve his lineage I mean
he was sentenced to death for killing a
pimp and the Templars faked that death
and found a way to get him out of here
that's a much more interesting movie
than this it's the Apple to be done Kyle
I believe it exists the Bible tells us
it contained two seated mugs first
disobedience um no I have read Genesis
about six dozen times in my life and it
does not mention anything about a metal
round object housing the seeds of Adam
and Eve sinful decisions we should read
the Bible more you think with a building
this size they'd be able to keep the
basketball court in the cafeteria is
separate from each other
you said it Fassbender you said it since
this is the fourth or fifth time Cal
hallucinates Aguilar followed by zero
plot advancement I can only assume the
director keeps showing it to us until he
can think of what happens next
actually wait are we supposed to be
putting ideas or just for taking this
role in this movie maybe didn't you call
Jake Gyllenhaal or Taylor Kish for
advice before accepting this thing
smoked in this movie I mean it's like
late 15th century Europe was constantly
on fire some coming up for the good CGI
you losers i Game of Thrones imagery I
figured you'd make an appearance
somewhere during this ripoff Palooza as
these two get led to their execution I
am 100% confident that either will and
Elizabeth the Turner or Jackie Chan's
girlfriend from Shanghai knew who will
rescue them at the last minute man
Kristen Stewart really wants to show her
hard side well if not Kristen Stewart
well my penis sure thinks it is wait can
we cut that last part third person here
might want to back up his ensemble
belongs nowhere near a fire I'm we glad
that asshole intimidatingly stuck the
knife here if not he would have been
burned at the stake they've never need
to find cow in this movie wouldn't exist
I would also be in all of this if I knew
what it meant I don't
so not all so what are we even doing
here is a movie he's remembering this
they're seeing him remember this but
everything has decided already hundreds
of years ago there was zero suspense and
even then negative suspense when you
backed her in that I don't know who to
report here given how little information
I've been shown about Aguilar on his
phone just for fun let's count the cups
in this very short fight sequence 1111
cups in 25 seconds I know some of the
super-proud of this work but that
someone is bad and should feel bad shoot
action so you don't have to cut up the
threads goddamn it disappears so born
means Doctor Strange it should have
credited Matt Damon or Benedict
Cumberbatch somewhere in here yep cut
cut cut cut
you know what I'm just going to add 10
more bulk Sims for all the over cut
action in that pink smoke and we won't
mention either ever again okay top of
this building has full access this movie
is 12 percent Apple 14% Bert
so Aguilar jumps from a panting height
and instead of seeing how he actually
survived movie just cuts back account
hopes I won't be pissed off about it
well that guy here RJ if you go in there
a few own free will well is he going in
of his own free will if he knows that
being forced to go and will kill him
happens and tempers have been at war for
centuries Wow just like the werewolves
and vampires is there anything I can do
how about you let me out of here wait I
thought you're not surprising her here
come so what's changed why does he have
to ask to leave now I had to negotiate
you mean manipulate how is this
manipulation he's wanted to kill his
father the whole time
oh well and it's done is set him up to
do just that if anyone here has been
manipulated it's me I'm the one who gave
20th Century Fox money for basically
nothing in return
Oh contains the genetic code for free
will what also a free will is
genetically coded then that would mean a
series of proteins which are physical
things create free will also also
Brendan Gleeson was like Jeremy Irons
told me I should take this role without
explaining how embarrassed I'd be after
so when I read the script I quit but
then the studio backed a truck full of
money and body oil up to my door and
well here I am I don't want to jinx
anything but we haven't seen that damn
bird enough how they don't completely
shatter that fing Apple during this
fight is beyond me let's all keep in
mind he was just stabbed in the side
kudos to this movie for even thinking
about the surface tension of the water
but also few movie for suggesting a
tiny-ass knife would have any impact on
whether Aguilar survives this
be back will be rips off Indiana Jones
and Steve Martin well there's something
I didn't see coming that in no way adds
to the movies intrigue or entertainment
value also let's not forget Columbus was
a look evil person even if Hollywood
keeps giving him the savior treatment
his remains returned to Spain scan emic
triangulate feels the need to continue
using a supercomputer map for something
that can be googled
even though she's right this is a little
presumptuous until she you know actually
finds it while all the action continues
around them sophia cal and the sort of
assassin ghosts are just standing around
the Animus chamber like they're waiting
for the screenwriter to tell them what
to do next not allow your father and i
are here to help you and your face off
with baltimore nothing is true
everything is permitted wish I'd learned
that before turning out to be an honest
good person like some kind of sucker me
fine so because his ghost mom presumably
named Martha showed up suddenly he flips
signs and Omar and the others just
welcomed them with open arms you're not
prepared for how much of this movie
second half is basically a glorified
prison riot look at all really those
heels we both know who found it Kalin
Aguilar I think they're trying to imply
that Sophia found it but Cal's memory
searching and legal faith did most of
the heavy lifting high up there sashings
Creek goddamnit roll credits already I
want to feel threatened by this Apple
but don't have the slightest idea what
it's doing is it releasing something
into the Earth's atmosphere that's going
to kill all the free will proteins in
our DNA thankfully for the assassins
this climax had taking place in a
Templar building or most everyone is
already wearing a hooded cloak allowing
them to blend in Cal was able to slew
man walk up to the CEO of Abstergo and
slit his throat while giving a speech
without anyone trying to stop him okay
so she found her dad dad said Lynch Ely
for me walked outside and we pan up over
the city here and the holy smoothie is
ending they thought they were going to
get a sequel for sure there's not to
ourselves to the future you must kiss
cry a fortune cookie must have fallen
into Charlotte Rampling script when she
was memorizing her lines food it should
have Batman 15 minutes of credits
Oh
[Music]
he was a semi god of the wind and seas
mr. Delacroix Rob will lead this world
but if you cheat my heart I'll ask your
forgiveness for a dog the rock - the
rock rock rock the rock to rock the rock
right the rock right here so much as a
mouse fart in here the rest of the night
I swear by God in sunny Jesus you will
all be to be infirmary
they called me Musa but my name is
Patsy's but the game is out there and if
you do play or get played solitaire
bottle very possible and it is not
longer than I can and we have
visit we have here we have this
Assassin's Creed movie could easily been
titled Apple search or Apple Creek or
Assassins Apple phone is the movie talks
about apples a lot do you like apples
and while apples are a healthy snack
they are no tourists for tasting like
apples and not delivering to your door I
mean whose last time you hear from the
Appleman look I know you want to snack I
do too it's one of our defining human
characteristics and if you want to snack
and stay healthy then naturebox is the
lost city of Atlantis you've been
looking for
tons of tasty snacks that are free of
additives and preservatives stuff is
tasty and good for you can't believe it
go to naturebox.com/tyler sins today and
you'll get three snacks free on your
first order that's amazing and when you
go to naturebox.com/tyler my sins you'll
see our personal favorite snacks
handpicked by the cinemasins gang you
can even order an entire box full of
just our favorites you
me right now y'all right so what are you
waiting for
do you hate snacks I love layout I love
lamp
now of course you know so head to
naturebox Commons today to get started
snacking healthy let's go people
homonym